hi I'm Carmen Berlin I'm the author of
let's take this offline a book about
service workers in this book you'll
learn everything you need to know about
service workers and go from writing your
very first service worker to having a
fully functional offline application and
I'm a huge fan of offline apps and today
I'm going to show you how to use online
and offline events to check for internet
connection for your users in real time
this is a really big deal for any app
that needs that consistent internet
access so let's get started so before we
actually start writing any code I
thought it would make some sense if we
took a look at a site that doesn't have
a Service Worker it doesn't have any
handling for if a user loses their
connection this is a really popular site
you've probably seen it before but if
you go into dev tools and head over to
application you can see that there is
not a serviceworker for this site and so
then if we check offline a lot of stuff
is going to go wrong so if we go over to
console we're getting all of these
errors because there's nothing to handle
for a user losing connection and it's
definitely something we want to handle
for because it's something that happens
a lot so now that we've seen what can
happen if you don't have anything to
handle for losing connection let's now
take a look at some code for actually
handling for users losing connection so
now that we have noticed what's going to
happen if we don't take into account our
users losing their internet having their
internet come back let's take a look at
how we might handle for these kinds of
situations so we're gonna head over to
this code pin get rid of our console for
now so this is just a really simple code
pin that I made it just does one thing
it has some events that
handle for online and offline so I'm
going to pop this out into its own
window real quick reopen dev tools and
the head right back over to application
when I check offline notice that dotsub
I am offline and then if we go back
online see it switches to where it says
I am online so that is being done with
some event handlers so let's head back
over here and in the JavaScript we have
these two functions right here we attach
them to window just so they're top level
and we use online as the event listener
and all we're really doing is changing
the text within a span over in the HTML
but the important part here is using
this online event listener and then to
finish it out we also have an online
event listener and within that we're
changing the text to read offline
instead and so that's both of those are
what allow the switching back and forth
between online and offline so if you're
wondering what kind of situations this
would be good for you might if you want
to have the event listeners have a
notification bar at the top of your page
that says a user is offline and they
won't be able to access things right now
you could also wrap your Ajax requests
in an if block and that would look like
this so we would say if navigator dot
online with a capital L and then here we
would do our Ajax request and what this
will do for us is it will either it's it
returns a boolean and so it'll come back
true and if the person is online it'll
go ahead and go do the Ajax request or
if it is resolving with fall
it won't do our Ajax requests and so
back at the beginning of the video we
had on the other website they weren't
handling four requests and so what was
happening was when we went offline all
of a sudden they were getting all these
errors in their console and so if we do
just this really simple if block right
here we won't have that problem on our
site and so that is really all I had
remember to check out my book it is at
serviceworker book calm the book comes
out July 2nd so you'll want to go ahead
and preorder while the prices are still
low you'll learn everything you need to
know about serviceworkers going from
writing your very first serviceworker to
having a completely functional offline
application check that out and you can
also follow me on twitter i am karma Lu
thanks bye